employees from TACA TACA solutions
collect trash twice a week in kengamine
a post fooling neighborhood on the
outskirts of Nairobi susan Karenga
decided to use TACA TACA service she
lacks the front love the company
recycles the trash it collects no no
zhudi happy with the way they work I
really like this initiative they're
cleaner than bins TACA TACA solution
serves 6,000 households in kangay me a
nearby kawari several firms have
realized the commercial potential of
collecting trash in poor neighborhoods
the trouble is most of the garbage ends
up on illegal dumps TACA TACA is the
only company hair but also recycles its
trucks take 12 tons of trash every day
to the sorting Center and can give me
TACA TACA by the way is a swahili word
for trash daniel puffing holes
who is swiss founded the company in 2011
he lived in nairobi as a teenager a new
about its garbage problem a start-up is
backed by a number of international
development aid organizations it is now
starting to break even poppenhouse wants
to expand its operations we would want
to become like a wholesale waste manager
so we want other companies to come to us
but now in order for to incentivize them
we need to be able to accept their waste
at a very low fee and so we need to
become more and more efficient each SOTA
processes 400 kilograms of trash a day
if they manage more they get a bonus
there are 100 people on the payroll
Ruth Money bomb accounts based pay is
the equivalent of only 100 euros a month
still she likes a hot job and that she
is doing something for the environment
the past three years have been here at
Caen gaming but it was not like the way
it is now because there was at least the
dirty and at the moment it is doing our
twist the company now has clients
the city including shopping malls and
hotels it is looking for more firms to
take the materials it recycles in our
country like in Kenya people have not
embraced so much the recyclable part of
it so it's making sure people understand
what what we do and making sure people
embrace using more recyclables
creativity and flexibility are needed to
make a recycling operation like this
work in Nairobi track poorer residential
customers the process for collection are
staggered as a company we'd always like
to charge more if possible but that
doesn't work like it so especially in
low-income areas you need to be able to
charge very little otherwise people just
don't have the ability to sign up
TACA TACA solutions sometimes comes to
an international school in Nairobi to
talk to the kids about the importance of
recycling an environmental protection
brer burned school separate its trash
not many schools households do that in
Kenya
parents love the fact that we have that
we do this and that when we say we're
hoping the children will be responsible
citizens responsible global citizens and
we are actually doing this I've
certainly I've shown parents around
before who are new to the school and
they've been very impressed seeing the
bins and in fact somebody said to me
once I chose your school because I saw
the bins the company also holds
workshops at regular Qingyun schools to
raise awareness of these issues but so
far few of them have chosen to separate
their trash or recycle
it's not a short-term approach but over
time there will be the ones who will
hopefully you know push things towards
recycling on a larger level so if you
create that awareness early on I think
that's helpful going forward
- hold social enterprises taking root
TACA TACA solutions provides work and
helps the environment it's helping to
solve very material problems and also to
change attitudes in society